2 1 Zer blast off for India's latest
space mission launched from the easn
coast of the Indian Island of Sri harac
cotta ader L1 is
off on a 1 and a half million kilm
quests to study the sun's outer
layers and we have a confirmation of AD
L1 separation the mission has been
accomplished and with that some relief
for scientists of the ground control of
the Indian space research organization
or
ISRO the craft is heading for lrange
point1 also known as L1 where the
gravity of the Earth and Sun are
balanced the ad L1 will take its Journey
after some Earth manuvers it will start
its Journey to the L1 Point uh very long
journey of almost 125 days so let us
wish all the very best to adya
spacecraft it's says the orbiters
specialized instruments will study the
three outer layers of the sun we are
going to get the complete picture if if
I put in a layman terms it's like we're
going to get the black and white image
the colored image and the high
definition image 4K image of the Sun so
that we don't miss out on anything
that's happening on the sun scientists
say the probe could also shed light on
solar weather an objective a science
goal of trying to understand um the
activity of the sun um in particular how
that um show itself as solar flares um
and more extreme events called coronal
mass ejections we're more and more
reliant on satellites um for our
day-to-day lives um and particularly um
strong solar activity can actually
affect some of those satellites that we
that we rely on it's been just over a
week since India carried out its first
landing of a Rover near the moon's South
Pole it's only the fourth country to
successfully carry out Al Luna Landing
and this latest success is propelling
India into becoming one of the leading
players in outer space Laura Khan Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer